are you ready to make the best no-bake
dessert you will ever try I'm samadata
and here are my no-bake salted caramel
cookie dough bars line a loaf pan with
parchment paper in a medium Bowl combine
the ingredients for the cookie dough
press it into the loaf pan using your
hands until it's evenly packed
throughout the Pan place in the fridge
to set for 15 minutes so in a separate
Bowl mix together the ingredients for
The Salted Caramel the cookie dough is
done napping so remove it from the
fridge and add the caramel right on top
use a spoon to make sure it's evenly
spread throughout the Pan place
everything in the fridge to set for 15
minutes more is more when it comes to
Chocolate so now it's time to melt the
chocolate chips and coconut oil together
in your microwave in 15 second
increments until it's completely smooth
and glossy like lip gloss but chocolate
pour the melted chocolate on top of the
caramel and smooth until even time for a
flaky salt moment add the flaky salt on
top and place back into the fridge for
about 30 minutes to set now for the best
part slice into bars and enjoy
immediately